Sie sind die elegantesten Vögel
im europäischen Luftraum:
die Kraniche.
Auf dem Darß,
an der deutschen Ostseeküste,
kommen sie zweimal im Jahr zu Besuch,
um sich Kraft anzufuttern,
im Herbst für den Zug nach Süden, im
Frühjahr, um zu ihren Brutgebieten zu fliegen.
Biodiversitätsexpertin Marie-Yon Strücker
von der Umweltbehörde UNEP
möchte sich das Naturschauspiel
genauer anschauen.
An ihrer Seite: Jörg Schmiedel,
der als Kranichexperte für den BUND
an der Ostseeküste arbeitet.
Auf der Insel da hinten sehe ich
schon ein paar Kraniche, jetzt.
Ja, ja, es kommen jetzt laufend wieder welche
hinein, bis in die späte Dämmerung,
und dann sind sie da komplett,
rasten alle im Schutz der Insel.
Ich sehe, jetzt kommt auch noch so’n
Schiffchen vorbei.
Viele Leute kommen auch vorbei, um die
Kraniche zu sehen, speziell hier, oder?
Ja, ja, das ist der Renner! Also,
alle Fahrgastschifffahrtsbetriebe der Region,
die sind ausgebucht zur Kranichrastzeit.
Ist das denn nicht störend für die Kraniche?
Also, das ist doch eigentlich
’n Naturschutzgebiet.
Dürfen die Schiffe da
überhaupt richtig fahren?
Ja, hier vorne ist Fahrrinne. Er macht’s richtig.
Aber es ist auch schon wichtig,
dass der Nationalpark mit seiner
Nationalparkwacht hier
hin und wieder mal Präsenz zeigt.
Das heißt nicht,
dass die Leute gleich verhaftet werden,
aber schon sehr deutlich darauf hingewiesen
werden, dass sie hier unter anderem
auch die wirtschaftliche Existenzgrundlage
der Region zerstören würden.
In einer Kranichsaison kann man
bis zu 90.000 graue Kraniche
auf der Halbinsel Darß beobachten. Und das
hat einen historisch interessanten Grund.
Die Region liegt unterhalb der Seegrenze der
ehemaligen DDR. Deshalb waren
große Gebiete der Mecklenburgischen
Boddenlandschaft Sperrgebiet,
das weder wirtschaftlich entwickelt
noch stark besiedelt war.
Es gab also Platz und Ruhe für die Kraniche.
Während des Kalten Krieges war die gesamte
Küste mit Wachtürmen gesäumt,
die die Flucht von DDR-Bürgern in den
Westen verhindern sollten.
Nur die Tiere kümmerte die Grenze nicht.
Nach der Wende wurden –
zum Glück für die Kraniche – große Teile der
Grenze in ein Naturschutzgebiet verwandelt,
das sogenannte Grüne Band. Jetzt, mehr als
30 Jahre nach der Wiedervereinigung,
gibt es nur noch eine Handvoll
Grenztürme – wie hier in Klausdorf,
wo er eine Touristenattraktion geworden ist,
mit bestem Blick auf die Küste.
Oh, das ist ’ne Aussicht.
Herrlich, ne?
Sehr schön.
Und hier kann man das Grüne Band richtig
gut sehen, oder?
Ja, genau. Wir sind hier an der nördlichsten
Festlandkante Mecklenburg-Vorpommerns.
Dort befindet sich das Grüne Band.
Dahinter kommt gleich die Insel Bock,
die Insel Hiddensee
und dann die Insel Rügen.
Weiter nördlich geht’s nicht
auf dem Festland.
Die Vorpommerische Boddenlandschaft ist
ein Nationalpark mit strengen Regeln
für die Besucher,
damit die Strände naturbelassen bleiben.
Das war nicht immer so: Am 1. Oktober 1990,
zwei Tage vor der Wiedervereinigung,
wurde der Nationalpark als eine der letzten
Amtshandlungen der DDR eingerichtet.
Seit damals setzt sich Annett Storm für
den Umweltschutz am Bodden ein.
Also, Annett, erzähl doch noch mal ganz kurz,
was genau ist eigentlich dein Job,
oder was machst du eigentlich hier?
Also, ich bin die Vorsitzende vom
Förderverein des Nationalparks
Boddenlandschaft. Und wir haben dann
wirklich auch gleich, als die Wende kam
oder sich das alles abzeichnete,
haben wir gesagt‚
wir wollen hier irgendwas
für den Naturschutz tun
und haben mit Freunden diesen Verein
gegründet und haben uns dafür eingesetzt.
Es gab schon auch runde Tische, also,
dass der Nationalpark gegründet wurde,
ist eine Bewegung aus dem Volke heraus.
Inzwischen gibt es eigentlich
kaum jemanden noch,
der den Nationalpark infrage stellt.
Im Gegenteil, die größten Kritiker
sind heute Befürworter,
weil sie merken, dass es auch für sie einen
Vorteil hat.
Hier an der Küste findet man immer noch
Bernstein, das [der] von den Kiefern,
Stieleichen und Rotbuchen des
Darßer Waldes stammt.
Im Nationalpark wird der Wald urwüchsig,
ohne Eingriffe durch den Menschen belassen.
Und durch das feuchte Klima
und den Schutz hat sich hier
eine besondere Artenvielfalt angesiedelt.
Diese Feuchtgebiete werden immer seltener
in Mitteleuropa,
sind aber lebenswichtig für den Kranich.
Wenn sie im Frühjahr aus dem Süden in
die Boddenlandschaft zurückkehren,
finden sie hier Schutz und Nahrung
nach der langen Reise.
Und manche Kranichpärchen bringen hier
sogar ihren Nachwuchs auf die Welt.
Kraniche gelten als eine der Tierarten,
die die Menschen auch emotional erreichen
und dadurch für den Naturschutz werben.
Kraniche brauchen eigentlich
das ganze Jahr Feuchtgebiete.
Während der Rast, jetzt,
brauchen sie die Feuchtgebiete
als Schlafzimmer –
also die stehen im flachen Wasser,
um dort Schutz vor Prädation zu haben.
Noch wichtiger sind die Feuchtgebiete
während der Reproduktion.
Das heißt, Kraniche bauen ihre Nester auf
dem Boden. Und um Schutz vor Prädatoren,
beispielsweise in Deutschland
vor Füchsen, zu haben,
muss das von Wasser umgeben sein.
Und insofern ist der Kranich derjenige,
mit dem man sehr gut Feuchtgebietsschutz
betreiben kann. Also, der ist einfach sichtbar.
Der Kranichschutz Deutschland begleitet und
beobachtet die Vögel ganz genau.
Jungtiere werden teilweise beringt und mit
GPS-Sendern versehen,
damit man mehr über die Flugrouten und
das Verhalten der grauen Kraniche erfährt.
Am Günzer See wird zusätzlich Mais
und Weizen für die Tiere ausgelegt
und damit auch der Besucherstrom gelenkt.
So können internationale Vogelbeobachter die
Kraniche tanzen sehen, ohne sie zu stören.
Auch Marie-Yon Strücker
trifft Günter Nowald hier,
an einem der größten
Kranichrastplätze der Welt.
Die ehemalige Grenze der DDR hat an der
Ostsee einen Image-Wandel vollzogen.
Hier schafft man es, Naturschutz, Tourismus
und wirtschaftliche Interessen
miteinander zu verbinden und gleichzeitig
den Lebensraum des Kranichs zu erhalten.